hey guys today it is time for another
video request how to increase your
testosterone naturally
now this is a super important question
and every guy is supposed to know the
answer to this question because as a man
your testosterone affects well pretty
much everything your brain hormones
muscle mass sperm production libido
behavior traits hair growth bone density
skin issues fat metabolism and even
heart health
now there are clear signs or symptoms of
having low testosterone so listen to
this and see if you might have low
testosterone reduced bone mass muscle
mass and a reduced sex drive you're
always tired a decrease in energy levels
fat gain hair loss you get mood swings
erection problems your testicles got
smaller you're struggling to sleep and
you might have low self-esteem so you
see how testosterone influences your
whole life so in this video i'm quickly
going to give you five tips to increase
to boost your testosterone
and if you stick all the way to the end
i'll give you a bonus tip as well let's
start with the first one
[Music]
eat more fish like tuna salmon and
sardines you need to eat this because of
the vitamin d
it is shown in studies that vitamin d
can boost your testosterone up to 90
percent
according to grass medical university
this is one of the reasons why i love
fishing got the first fish
40 kilos taking a line again
because then i know the fish that i eat
is not farmed and full of unhealthy
stuff now oysters are another good
option because of the zinc which will
improve your sperm health oysters have
more zing than any other food option out
there but if you can't get to oysters if
you can't eat it then other good options
are red meat
beans poultry
nuts and mussels and then other foods
that will also increase your
testosterone are eggs pomegranates beef
liver honey grapes garlic
ginger cabbage
green vegetables olive oil and onions
now let's move to number two
[Applause]
stay away from beer
yeah you probably already know that beer
is not good for your body but you might
not have known that it also decreases
your testosterone yeah webmd says it
takes only five days of regular drinking
for your testosterone level to drop
alcohol may throw off many parts of your
body's hormone system now listen to this
heavy drinkers can have shrunk
intestines testicles thin chest and
beard hair and higher levels of the
female hormone estrogen yeah maybe it's
time to stop drinking
hit the gym and i'm not talking about
doing cardio i'm talking about lifting
weights because it is one of the best
ways to increase your testosterone new
studies show that resistance training is
the best thing that you can do to boost
your testosterone levels for the short
term and the long term
and don't skip leg days i'm guilty of
that myself oh before i forget if you
like this video so far chances are
you're probably gonna like the rest of
my channel as well so remember to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you'll be notified whenever i upload
a new video i would love the support
let's move on to the next one
[Music]
sleep enough if you sleep enough like
let's say seven to eight hours your
testosterone levels will increase but if
you don't of course they will decrease
for example if you only get five hours
sleep instead of seven to nine it can
drop to around fifteen percent
[Music]
plastic
you have to eat more out of plastic
plates and cups
i'm kidding
it's exactly the opposite most plastics
have bpa which means bisphenol a
now this is a bad chemical that can
decrease your testosterone and mess with
your hormones
always remember to look for the bpa free
sign whenever you have to use
plastic
now the bonus tip
you have to stress less now i know this
is a tough one especially in the world
that we live in this rat race that we
call life but you have to control your
life instead of your life controlling
you if you stress too much your cortisol
levels will increase which will then
lower your testosterone now some of you
guys who've been with me from the start
when i started my youtube channels you
know that i don't really experience
stress yeah i have a busy life i have
two youtube channels that i'm running
there's also another project that's
going to be very interesting i'll
announce that pretty soon but with all
of that i don't experience stress i live
a fast-paced life but it is full of
purpose and peace
this is a piece that this temporary
world cannot give you now are you
struggling with stress
you tried a lot of things and nothing
seems to work and it's influencing your
whole life
if you want to know what helps me
this is just the truth this is not a
quick fix trick thing no this is just
the honest truth of what really helps me
and come and check out this video it's
from my other channel and you might find
the answers that you're looking for as
well
and before you go always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys